[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH GORDON: Hey, everyone.
My name's Josh Gordon.
I'm here with the Developer
Show at the TensorFlow Developer
Summit, and Daniel
Smilkov, who is
one of the authors
of TensorFlow.js.
And it's one of my favorite
launches of the year.
So Daniel, thank you so
much for joining us today.
DANIEL SMILKOV: Thank you.
I'm really glad
you liked the talk.
So TensorFlow.js is a JavaScript
library for machine learning
that can run entirely
in the browser.
And you can both use
your model for reference
or do training in the browser.
So you could take an
existing model in Python--
there are a lot of
models out there
that people have written--
and you can use one of our
tools to automatically convert
that model and import
it in the browser.
And then it can build creative
applications and visual apps
around that.
The way TensorFlow.js
started was
from a different library
called deeplearn.js
that we initially released.
And deeplearn.js had
a lower level API
that only had lean algebra ops.
With the launch today,
deeplearn.js joining TensorFlow
family, we're adding a new
layer of high level ops that
is aligned with DF
layers and Keras
so people can just use
high-level building
blocks and best
practices to build
RNNs or convolutional
neural networks.
JOSH GORDON: So for
instance, if I'm a developer
and I've implemented
a model already
on my desktop in
Keras or TensorFlow,
or a combination of both,
then I can export it?
DANIEL SMILKOV: Yes.
You can do any TensorFlow
SaveModel or Keras model.
You can use our Pit package.
We just released the
TensorFlow.js Pit package
in Python.
Run that script
pointing to the artifact
where your model is saved.
And it will produce a
different set of files
that you can then
use in the browser.
JOSH GORDON: And one thing I
really like about TensorFlow.js
is you have an
outstanding examples
directory that demonstrates how
to accomplish things like this.
DANIEL SMILKOV: That's one
very cool part about the web,
is that people can easily
fork these examples,
launch them in the browser,
modify them, upload them
in their own servers, and
share it with everyone.
JOSH GORDON: OK,
so now, let's talk
about some of your
great live demos.
There's the Teachable Machine,
the Emoji Scavenger Hunt,
and Pac-Man.
DANIEL SMILKOV: All
very cool demos.
Teachable Machine is one
of our earliest demos.
It was a collaboration with
Google Creative Lab folks.
It runs a neural
network in the browser.
And then you can train
it with your webcam
and associate it with
one of the four actions.
And people love it.
JOSH GORDON: So I actually
like that so much, I
taught a course last
semester, and had
all my students
build a Teachable
Machine as their final project.
They loved it, too.
DANIEL SMILKOV: I'm
very glad to hear that.
JOSH GORDON: Yeah.
OK, so the Emoji Scavenger
Hunt and Pac-Man.
DANIEL SMILKOV: Yes,
so the Emoji Scavenger
Hunt is another game that our
friends at Google Brand Studio
built. This one actually
uses our latest tools.
So it uses the TensorFlow
[? Reports ?] tutorial,
takes a pre-trained mobile net.
Then they are retraining it to
identify 400 different objects
that you can have in your home.
Then they're using our
Automatic Converter tool
to port it in the browser.
And they turn it into a game.
The goal of the game is you
can run it on the phone,
uses the webcam.
And you point it to an object.
It gives you an emoji.
And you have to find the
real object in real life,
point it, and make the
model predict correctly
before the time runs out.
And I just want to point
out that everything
runs in the browser.
No data is being
sent to any server.
JOSH GORDON: So this is
valuable for privacy-preserving
applications, as well.
DANIEL SMILKOV: Yes.
JOSH GORDON: But let me
make a quick comment.
So when I think
of web browser, I
think of opening
Chrome on my laptop.
But I just realized, from
what you're saying, of course,
I can develop a
TensorFlow.js app
and also open it from
a mobile browser.
So you have a last awesome
demo, which is Pac-Man.
So tell me about Pac-Man.
DANIEL SMILKOV: So Pac-Man
is a demo that kind of
joins the '80s game and the
machine learning technologies
from 2018 together.
And it shows you how you
can take a pre-trained model
and retrain it with your own
private data in the browser.
So what we do is, I use my face
to turn it into a controller
and teach a neural network to
recognize my different poses as
left, right, up, or down.
And then I play Pac-Man.
JOSH GORDON: So you can control
Pac-Man by moving your face.
DANIEL SMILKOV: Yeah.
JOSH GORDON: That's really cool.
DANIEL SMILKOV: So even though
it looks like, you know,
just a game, it actually
has huge implications
for accessibility.
Think of someone building
a Chrome extension
that can then
recognize these actions
and allow people
to browse the web.
JOSH GORDON: That's
a great point,
so for paralyzed patients
and stuff like that.
OK, so this is awesome.
To wrap it up, where is the
best place for developers
to go to get started?
DANIEL SMILKOV: Go
to js.tensorflow.org.
We have a beautiful website
with a lot of examples.
Each example you can
easily fork, modify, share.
And also, we have tutorials.
Feel free to dive in.
JOSH GORDON: Awesome.
So Daniel, thanks so much.
For the Developer Show at
the TensorFlow Dev Summit,
I'm Josh Gordon.
Thanks again, and I'll
see you next time.